when did you decide that you wanted to
go solo cuz I mean you've been in a
group for so long and there's a comfort
that goes with you right no I mean I
first started solo work ten years ago
now when I was 14 when I first thought
if economy do that ever since but I was
I was in the band's long summer then
when I got out the band I didn't really
know what I wanted to do I needed a bit
of time to get my head around it I don't
we have really celebrated our success
that we had so for me was there was a
little bit of time where I just sat back
and like I breathed it in a little bit
and got my head back in the game of what
if normality was because I mean we were
playing every single day different city
different state different place you know
it was crazy and we net you know there
was a lot for a long time we were just
locked in hotel room is a bit I'd say it
was bad it was the most wild adventure
of ever being it was you know at times
he did get hard so I needed a little bit
of time afterwards just to go right what
do you really want to do for this like
where do you really want to go and you
know I wasn't just gonna sit home and
kick about past the time you know I've
performed my first and foremost I have
to go out there and get back on with
that and get on with it he did Liam
found incredible success with the debut
single from his upcoming album strip
that down which recently passed 1
million streams and he's recently teamed
up with Rita Ora on the song for you a
track from the FME soundtrack to the
film Fifty Shades freed waiting for her
left
I'm in the game now I love it you're
fully in it though glad I I made this
decision yeah and everyone is embracing
you you know with open arms what's that
feel like
oh it's been amazing I mean from you
know the way the fanbase has reacted to
the songs and you know that I don't even
see a lot because I'm at home a lot the
time with my boy but then I you know
when I come out and see your how much
it's been playing on the radio and
people tell me other different facts and
things about it but you'd really go well
yeah so it's a super exciting and indeed
it's the best but how did you decide on
you know on your sound like you said
you've been I mean that was the most
difficult thing with the sound because
you know what I work with a lot of
different people throughout the music
industry and they always bring their 10%
of what their flavor is onto it like
chart like Charlie puth for example
amazing writer people don't even know
anything about choice butplease either
bar
[Music]
he brings a certain thing to a song
Pharrell brings a certain thing to a
song eh earrings so you know it was all
those different things and I think in
the end we've ended up with a very
eclectic mix but there's a uniform
across what goes on there but you know I
wrote and write loads of different songs
for different people and different stuff
so it was always gonna be a bit of a
mixer match and I think you know your
first album you're always trying to find
your feet a little bit with what it is
what works what doesn't work yes mm-hmm
it's eclectic and it's like I kind of
went across justified confessions
you know 8701 one favorite album when I
was a kid yeah you know those are things
I hope postmarks least listen to the
music than was going wrong or something
was going right or you know there's
different songs that so I wanted to
recreate something like that for this
generation I guess yeah but that sort of
music so I mean I hope I've done that
job but you know more than anything we
just wanted like really good hits and
stuff that you want to do you know this
is your chance to go solo and enjoy what
you like and I yeah I love rap music I
love dance music so it's kind of a mix
of all those sort of things and what's
it like performing by yourself out on
the stage again I mean it's great I've
got my I have like a troupe of dances
with me as well so I never feel like
truly alone on stage yeah
well it's great you know I mean you kind
of phase out a little bit when you're on
stage and you and you you just kind of
go into a little world of your own
minutes exactly it's like being on
autopilot almost but you're in control
so I don't know it's a very strange
feeling